well you know man i look i mean your
body of work is just like
you know you're always doing something
and it's hard to understand too i
envy you not not only because you work a
lot it's not about that it's more about
the energy i look at like all the things
you do and like you go from seven
seasons on castle and i thought you'd
learn your lesson and say that's enough
work
that's enough work i was the lead and
then you go into the rookie
and then you're doing all these other
things and is it is it that you love
i've asked this question every once in a
while but is it that you love the work
so much
that you just want to work or is it that
you don't want to be
not working or you don't like being
alone what is is there some kind of uh
psychological thing there or is it just
you love work i don't
get it uh i am not the guy who has to
spend all my
time working i like a balance i do like
a balance
i have been fortunate enough that uh
there's been a couple of jobs that have
kept me working
for long periods of time so it may
appear from the outside
that i i really like to work that's just
luck of the draw of being on some jobs
that
that that tend to last a little while
and
that's not usually the
how it works which is you know that you
know that how many years was smoke so
well i did seven but remember thomas tom
was in every episode like you are in
every episode so how do you have free
time
because the one thing if i had two weeks
off i'd be worried about my lines for
the next script
uh i yeah on castle it was a little
different because i i didn't have a lot
of time off so i was really
precious with my time off i wasn't
trying to work outside of
of castle uh as far as how do you
remember your lines
my first gig was a soap opera all right
and the days of our lives one life to
live one life too late
yes thank you and uh they sent me to an
acting coach and she said
you already know how to act i'm just
gonna teach you how to break down a
script
so you can remember your lines and she
taught me a way that i used to this day
i used to do it painstakingly you know
on paper and pen and have to study and
do those
but now it's just a it's just a muscle
wait a minute so there's a trick to the
thing there's a there's a breakdown a
certain way to learn them that helps you
i mean
i i just no one ever taught me anything
i mean i took acting classes and then i
got did a lot of plays
but i just went over and over and over
and over and stressed myself out
there's an easier way to do it something
that's what is your process
when you start with a character where do
you start and how do you get to your
character how do you find things like
what is
you have a process right yeah i feel
like okay this is what i want to do
and now once i feel like i got this
i or sometimes i tend to learn the lines
first
and then find the character in the lines
and learning
so it's a different thing but i always
am curious about how people do that
because when you're on castle and you're
on rookie and you're doing these movies
are you the guy that wakes up and
they're like uh nate nathan do they say
native they say nathan
okay they say can i get you a coffee and
you're like yeah and then you learn
lines right in the chair
yes yes i'm reading the lines in the
chair
um then you go in you do a camera
rehearsal you do a couple rehearsals you
know like that
and you get a little bit of a layout so
that educates you and then how other
people are doing their lines and where
that kind of
life lives that educates you a little
bit and you go okay i got it now
and then you run it a couple more times
as you're getting changed and that's all
you need really and then you just then
you're just running it and running it
and running it
if you make a mistake they go back it's
not like you have to be amazing and
perfect
every time all the time but there's got
to be a speech that you have to give
that you you know i might need to go
over this the night before
uh i won't lie to you i had like a three
page it wasn't a monologue but it was
there was a lot
to say and that's it's a lot for even me
and i'm good at that part of it but that
was
a lot and uh at that point you do feel
some responsibility if you
make a mistake you're the one holding
things up and that's just the one thing
i never want to be is the one people are
waiting on
just be ready there's a lot of time in
the day that you can use
when it's your time to work just be
ready do you get frustrated with other
people if they don't know their lines
uh listen sometimes people get nervous
and they don't have the pr
i have so much practice i have so much
practice
uh i think folks come and their stakes
are a little higher when they're a guest
star sometimes the stakes get higher if
they make a mistake they feel terrible
and i say hey
uh if you feel like super duper bad
about messing up a line it'll educate
the crew
that maybe i should start feeling bad
when i mess up the line
i don't want them to have that kind of
expectation i believe that you do that
because i've heard that you do that
where you've been on set and you're just
very comforting to guest stars and
things and
i've done that before too because coming
into someone's family
and expecting to be it's so intimidating
and i've been fortunate enough not to
have to do that
so you know not to be a guest star i
mean every once in a while but
to come in on a show that's already
rolling let's go and like
i have to be great i have to be great
here's nathan philly and [ __ ] he's the
lead he's watching we have to impress
him
i i well i can't tell you what they're
thinking i do know that uh
to be a guest on a show is a
is an art it's you have it's like being
a guest in someone's house you want to
be
relaxing listen i want people to be
relaxed in my home when people come to
my place of work i want them to be
relaxed there too because that's when
they're going to do their best work